your average skateboarder started and
got hooked on skateboarding because it
was different because it was different
than the team sports and it allowed a
lot of creative freedom and so your
general population of skateboarders are
really creative individuals that think a
bit outside the box so when that happens
you have their music tastes and their
clothing tastes and they make up words
for different things like slang terms
and it becomes really it becomes a trend
setter it really drives something new
into the media and it drives something
new that people start noticing different
musical tastes and different music
artists and like it's very evident how
skateboarding has changed fashion and
what people are wearing skate shoes have
become the norm you know people that are
walking around that don't skate aren't
really they just don't know that the
paneling on their shoe is made for
skating it's made because we need
support in these certain spots but now
that just becomes the look of a shoe
with the outside of the box thinking
these skaters they they have an
attention to detail whereas it might not
have come out in school or it might not
have come out in a lot of different ways
that people may have thought that you
know they they weren't bright when you
can break down skateboarding and you can
break down these little movements and
what would look good and you know
certain ways they turn in like a line
they'll turn one way and then turn back
the other way because they like the way
that that looks or the skate filmer will
film things so that the skater begins in
the left side of the frame weaves on
like on the opposite side of the frame
and then the next clip in this video
part will start the opposite way so that
your eyes move during the video it's
really creative and we
that in that attention to detail it goes
into every other part of their life that
they they start to tweak things a little
bit and so they start to talk different
and they make up slang terms with their
friends but those slang terms end up
making it into pop popular culture and
they end up making it into like hip hop
songs and things like that and then
they're also great at designing a lot of
skateboarders are artists and one of
their outlets is a skateboard and the
other one is doing art and then they
become popular artists that people don't
know that they actually started in
skateboarding and they they've had like
their graphics on boards for a long time
they start to design shoes and they
start to design clothing and doing
things doing things just differently and
it ends up being really refreshing for
you know the rest of popular culture
without these creative individuals you
we'd all be wearing like a uniform in a
way a skateboarders way of thought is so
different that I feel if somebody had
some sort of dilemma in their life you
could ask a skateboarder for an outside
opinion and outside of the box you may
be getting into a double-edged sword
because depending on which skateboarder
and what you're asking you may get
something that is absolutely ridiculous
or you can get something that's
absolutely brilliant
you